ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
太って服を脱いで他人に体当たりをする
神尾動物の形に居る頂上宇山を土でご飯を炊く
腹を切る気も立ちと一緒にお風呂に入る好きでもない人にプレゼントを買う謙遜する
小型のキーを押せば
てる祈るときに書いて打つ高を白く塗る丁寧に緑茶を作る袖の食べる服を着る
馬刺しを食べる勤勉に働く列に並ぶお世辞を言うとにかく謝る笑いを取るため人を叩く
帝国の5分前に到着するが靴を脱ぐ霊を信じる
怒ったときに舌打ちをするに磨いて義務的を意味する
喫煙するパって読む怪獣から逃げる省略する割り箸を歯ではある現金を見つけたらそれ
をなぜか交番に届ける
うがいをする病院に行く必ずメジャーを使う会社に残ってダラダラする栄養をとるわけ
もなく
だってという脚のナイスを買う子供を作らないとされたお茶を半分残すまゆ
芸をソウル自分は日本人じゃないというような言い方をする
で日本人こういうのは分からない
ぶどうの皮をむくだって現実でも芸の世界でも整髪料をたくさん使う
マヨネーズを付け spf 50の日焼け止めを塗るきれいに服をたたむハザード
ランプをつけて俺を u チップをしないテレビ番組で大げさな反応する家に
引きこもるあえて歯の矯正をしない論理的に考える郡
的に行動する書類を fax で送る目を細かく描く過ちを犯したら記者会見を開く者
会見で嘘泣きをする平和を守る座ってシャワーを浴びる
上記を全て無視して国際化する
ni